bom eu tenho privilégio de fi entre pec
com um microfone porque eu não mexo os
versos eu sofri um acidente de carro e
quebrou o pescoço e e aí assim num
primeiro momento eu perdi os movimentos
do pescoço para baixo e eu também parei
de respirar e não conseguia mais
respirar sozinho sem a sem o auxílio de
aparelhos
então eu ficava presa uma tomada é
respirando numa máquina e e fui pra cá
customizada que aquele furo que faz na
garganta
então eu também não falava porque não
sai há som
então vocês podem imaginar hoje pra mim
o que é estar diante do microfone
livre leve e solta sem da empresa tomada
e poder falar
o primeiro livro que chegou pra mim
quando eu estava na uti era um livro do
de pacs oprah e o título o nome do livro
era a cura quântica
comecei a ler esse livro e nesse livro
mostrava como você consegue fazer o
pensamento se transformar em matéria sim
tô falando de uma forma muito simplista
mas aquilo pra mim naquele momento na
uti e ele norteou toda a minha vida o
meu trabalho e tudo que eu faço hoje que
pra mim esse o pensamento pode produzir
matéria
então existe cura existe milagre
e pra mim existe um milagre ele
aconteceu naquele momento que o livro
chegou às minhas mãos
convivendo aqui no brasil com a situação
da pessoa com deficiência
e vem do o tamanho da da discriminação
que essas pessoas passam
foi quando eu resolvi fundar uma ong com
o objetivo de melhorar a qualidade de
vida das pessoas e eu sou muito grata
por ter tido muita oportunidade eu
comecei a me interessar vocês acreditam
pensar que na grécia antiga quando se
pensava em política pública e nessa
política pública aquelas pessoas que
eram disformes eram indicadas para a
eliminação para execução para a morte às
pessoas surdas por exemplo eram
consideradas pessoas sem capacidade de
aprendizado
aí assim com a evolução do tempo muitas
pessoas com deficiência passaram a ser
tratados de uma forma muito assistência
lista pessoas cegas por exemplo elas
ficavam retidos em hospitais
hoje a gente vê pessoas cegas circulando
eu tenho um cego na minha equipe que ele
pega ônibus cheio pega o metrô cheio vai
trabalho ele caminha numa metrópole
cheia o cego paulistano deve ser o cego
mais descolado do planeta porque ele tem
que pular os ambulantes sair correndo
é o som da cidade já é bastante caótico
em buraco no chão e ele consegue ir e
vir e chegar imagine esses ego
na idade média ele num não teria essa
possibilidade mesmo eu se eu fosse
avaliada por um médico do inss ele me
receitaria uma aposentadoria por
invalidez
assim pra gente ver
é a diferença de parâmetros que o tempo
traz a gente tem hoje
o primeiro documento de direitos humanos
que do século 21 que a convenção da onu
para os direitos das pessoas com
deficiência que o brasil ratificou
isso quer dizer o que quer dizer que
hoje a convenção da onu é uma norma
constitucional faz parte do nosso
ordenamento jurídico
mas na constituição tem peso de
constituição ou seja o autista ele está
dentro do documento da convenção da onu
e dentro de si com documento tem uma
coisa muito clara falta de
acessibilidade é discriminação e
discriminação é crime
portanto por falta de acessibilidade
a gente não entende só rampa ou elevador
a gente entende a falta de
acessibilidade na educação falta de
acessibilidade na comunicação falta de
acessibilidade no trato diário das
pessoas dentro dos serviços públicos e
privados que o país oferece
eu acho que o que mais falta no dia a
dia do nosso país é informação
informação que mostre entendeu as reais
necessidades da nossa população nunca
foi feito no nosso país uma campanha de
conscientização sobre o autismo
assim como no censo do ibge não se
questiona
não se pergunta se existe um autista
dentro daquela família e mesmo no que
diz respeito às pessoas com deficiência
no geral a gente não sabe a gente não
sabe quem são como vivem
que tipo de deficiência têm tem cadeira
tem aparelho auditivo está estudando
tá com saúde a gente não tem essas
informações
o censo do ibge é não traz e nunca vai
trazer nunca vai trazer porque o
aprofundamento que pela envergadura da
pesquisa não consegue fazer então os
municípios têm que fazer os municípios
têm que se responsabilizar por um
recenseamento que questione quem são os
munícipes como vivem como estão só assim
a gente vai ter política pública muito
mais estratégica porque a gente vai
saber quem é o público alvo
pra quem que a gente vai trabalhar
quando eu resolvi me candidatar a
deputada federal
o que eu mais ouvi foi que eu jamais
teria a saúde para ir e vir toda semana
e para brasília e e conseguir marcar com
um trabalho dessa magnitude
eu falo para vocês a única deputada que
eu não vejo reclamar das viagens ou eu
a galera record eu mesmo
é cansativo e assim eu estou sempre
pronta para pegar o avião para brigar no
nos aeroportos e nos aviões por conta de
questões de acessibilidade e aí o que
aconteceu nesse percurso todo onde
primeiramente eu fundei a ong
depois eu fui nomeada secretária a eu me
candidatei a vereadora
depois me candidatei a deputada e aí me
chega o privilégio de poder fazer a
relatoria do projeto de lei que
tramitava na casa que cria uma política
pública para a pessoa que têm transtorno
do espectro autista
eu entrei no mundo
é uma sorte de pais e mães que
articulados de uma forma que eu jamais
tinha visto e comecei a perceber que
eram pessoas que do dia que o filho
nasceu ou do dia que o filho apresentou
alguma algum comportamento que chamou a
atenção até hoje tinha ouvido não não
isso não aquilo não temos informação não
sabemos se a pesquisar e puxa nos
estados unidos
a última pesquisa que fizeram detectaram
que de 50 crianças human pode ter esse
transtorno do espectro autista e como
assim como não existe nenhuma política
pública
comecei a perceber pensar em
discriminação porque uma pessoa com
deficiência como a minha por exemplo é
uma discriminação que é meio óbvia
porque muitas vezes a pessoa as pessoas
o ser humano tem uma certa dificuldade
em lidar com aquilo que é diferente dele
e ele acabou ganhando né de uma forma
mais superficial até para não ter que
refletir sobre isso porque o pensamento
geralmente é se eu estivesse no lugar
dela eu não conseguiria lidar
eu não seria feliz então é melhor nem
pensar nisso pra nunca usar esse tipo de
esse tipo de sensação esse tipo de
emoção
agora a pessoa que tem o transtorno do
espectro autista ela muitas vezes sofre
uma discriminação que é mais velada
ainda porque tem umas sequelas
aparentemente invisíveis muitas vezes
então a gente acaba entrando num ceará i
tudo escuro da forma das pessoas
interagirem com isso e isso pode ser uma
das explicações pelo qual porque a gente
nunca teve política pública para esse
fim é porque a educação no nosso país
ela não é feita de tal forma que quem
tem que passar pelo pela privação é quem
tem que aprender a ensinar o professor
não existe ninguém que não tenha
capacidade de aprender
existe quem não tenha a capacidade de
ensinar e isso dia a dia a gente vem
detectando hoje é claro a gente tem
pessoas surdas que são professores que
têm de outra doutorado mestrado
hoje a gente tem pessoas um transtorno
do espectro autista que ensinam e muito
mas isso é uma mudança de atitude de
quem ensina
eu eu ouvi muitos nãos principalmente
quando eu estava no hospital que não ia
sentir isso que eu não ia mais poder
fazer aquilo que eu nunca mais vai poder
ficar em pé que eu era muito fraquinha
que coisas assim que no fundo não
condiziam com aquilo que com aquele com
aquela marca que eu tinha criado no meu
imaginário até então eu pensava porque
que de um dia para o outro eu quebro
pescoço e eu passei a ser tudo o que não
pode não consegue não é capaz como isso
pode acontecer na vida de uma pessoa
eu eu penso hoje que o meu mandato valeu
a pena
por conta desse projeto de lei e é claro
que não tem nada pronto
a gente precisa ainda muito trabalhar
pra que os serviços existem é
infelizmente as coisas aqui no brasil
elas num elas não se concluem porque uma
lei existe e pra isso a gente realmente
conta o trabalho das pessoas que têm
autismo e dos familiares mas tem umas
mudanças que elas são muito mais
profundas e passam pela mudança de
atitude do ser humano
eu sempre digo que não tem mal nenhum
quando a gente detecta que tem um
preconceito que tem uma barreira de
atitude que age de uma forma com uma
conduta que não seja inclusiva
não tem mal nenhum nisso mas tem muito
mau se a gente não quiser derrubar a
gente não quiser trabalhar para eliminar
esse tipo de atitude porque não tem
autismo como disciplina obrigatória na
faculdade de medicina
assim como não existe acessibilidade
como disciplina obrigatória a faculdade
de engenharia e arquitetura
assim como não existe uma disciplina em
pedagogia que faça com que o professor
tenha a responsabilidade intrínseca e a
força eo conhecimento para ensinar
aqueles que têm capacidade de aprender
fora do padrão que o professor aprendeu
não tem isso a gente tem que fazer
mudanças nas grades curriculares das
universidades têm uma história que me
chamou muito a atenção que a história
daquele a uma moça que é amanhã e ela
formada em enfermagem não conseguia
emprego
em lugar nenhum dessa cidade de são
paulo
por pura discriminação ela não conseguir
emprego que ela chegava e pela estatura
dela
as pessoas falavam que não tinha vaga
até que a beneficência portuguesa aqui
resolveu dar uma oportunidade pra ela
pra ela fazer durante um mês
o intensivão a 1 uma espécie de de treme
mesmo de experiência e ela no primeiro
dia de trabalho dela
o paciente dela teve uma parada cardíaca
o paciente que estava cuidando pois ela
não teve a mínima dúvida ela pulou em
cima da cama pulou em cima dele fez
aquela massagem cardíaca resgatou esse
paciente que não quis mais que nenhuma
outra enfermeiro atendesse e hoje é
chefe de enfermagem dentro da
beneficência portuguesa
a gente vê o quanto a gente tem falta de
informação o quanto a gente muitas vezes
têm limitação e imaginar o tamanho do
potencial de todas as pessoas
é eu procuro treinar minha equipe
pessoas de toda toda diversidade para
que a gente aprenda todo dia né pra que
a gente tenha demonstrações dia a dia do
que o ser humano é capaz e digo pra
vocês
a gente está sempre aquém da notícia a
gente está sempre sem saber do tamanho
da capacidade das pessoas
meu primeiro chefe de gabinete
quando eu fui secretária ele é cego e um
dia pedi pra ele e olhar um espaço
porque a secretaria não tinha espaço
ainda pra ocupá então ele foi junto foi
o secretário adjunto o olhar um outro
espaço
dois voltaram e o secretário adjunto que
enxergava ele fez uma descrição muito
breve ele falasse olha o espaço é grande
tem toalete acessível
acho que a gente vai ficar bem lá eo
guilherme que era o cego
ele vai falar assim o espaço tem uma
acústica muito boa pra gente tem uns 15
mesas
o carpete também o velho precisa ser
trocado
tem uma vista uma vista bem bonita para
uma avenida
tem umas duas do alex que não tão super
adequadas mas dá pra arrumar ficar
olhando aquela descrição minuciosa
eu falei assim meu deus isso nunca tinha
passado na minha cabeça que na hora que
eu mandei o guilherme
eu pensei assim passou os 20 minutos que
caiu a ficha até mandei um cego e olhar
um espaço
galera vou falar só secretária não bate
muito bem naquele momento caiu minha
ficha eu falei meu deus guilherme quando
tiver que ver alguma coisa vou mandar
você porque foi uma surpresa pra mim tão
grande por isso que não há mal nisso a
gente tem que se abrir para o
aprendizado
por isso que dizem nada a gente pensa na
contratação de pessoas com deficiência
dentro de uma empresa e por conta desse
projeto de lei hoje à pessoa autista ela
é considerada a pessoa com deficiência
então atende usufruir de todas as
conquistas porque em matéria de
legislação até que a gente tem bastante
legislação para a pessoa com deficiência
e de qualidade aprofundado
então hoje uma pessoa que é autista ela
pode participar da lei de cotas e onde
tal limite da pessoa com deficiência
dentro de uma empresa
porque as pessoas elas são meio óbvio né
pra ser compensando assim a ele é cego
então ele vai testar a pintura de
automóvel
o outro é surdo então coloca no lugar
super barulhento
o outro tem síndrome de down então ele
vai entregar papéis
essa é tipo modus operandi do ser humano
de pensar nessa coisa óbvia mas o limite
não tá na pessoa com deficiência está na
cabeça do gestor de rh é ele que não
consegue enxergar a pessoa fazendo outra
coisa
por isso hoje um projeto de lei que
estou relatando que era o estatuto da
pessoa com deficiência transmita anos
naquela casa e ea gente mudou de nome
vai ser lei brasileira da inclusão e uma
das questões na empregabilidade é
impedir a discriminação dentro de uma
empresa ela não pode mais ofertar apenas
um cargo de call center
ela é obrigada a ofertar para as pessoas
com deficiência todos os tipos de cargo
seja na diretoria na gerência na
coordenação porque porque as empresas
hoje aquelas que realmente fazem
inclusão com maestria
elas conseguem colocar pessoas de todos
os tipos
em todas as situações isso a diversidade
é conviver com essa diversidade faz com
que todos nós cresçamos faz com que
todos nós consigamos ter uma visão de
mundo muito mais ampla muito maior e é
isso que a gente quer dentro da escola
é a gente quer que uma criança conviva
com a outra que é amputada que tem
síndrome de asperger que esse tem
síndrome de down que é surda que tem
baixa visão que usa muletas que usa
cadeira porque quando a gente convive
com alguém que caminha de forma
diferente que fala que se como
rita de forma diferente que escreve de
forma diferente que faz qualquer coisa
de forma diferente é o nosso universo
que engrandece a nossa visão que passa a
ser muito mais 360 graus
por isso que eu digo que poder
participar pelo menos um pouco do
universo azul me trouxe uma concepção de
mundo muito maior
e hoje quando eu vejo alguém que vai me
cumprimentar e que tem um certo olhar
tem uma festa carinha tem um certo
jeitinho de caminhar
eu já seja nessa bateu uma coisa mais
forte dentro do meu peito
bem eu penso nossa que que gratidão que
eu tenho a deus por poder perceber que
têm essas pessoas existem né assim como
se fossem dádivas que vêm de outros
planetas e assim poder fazer com que
esse brasil seja um pouquinho mais
acolhedor às diferenças
é uma função e orgulha mas é uma função
gratificante
eu deixo aqui meu abraço carinhoso né
minha vontade de transformar o mundo num
mundo mais azul no mundo mais
democrático mais inclusivo mais humano
ea gente precisa precisa muito além dos
familiares
o que a gente mais precisa é das pessoas
que têm autismo porque elas que vão
ensinar a cada dia como lidar com elas e
como democratizar mais essa situação
e poder fazer com que as pessoas tenham
esse privilégio de conviver e de ter uma
concepção de mundo muito maior
obrigado